on commence par du rugby les joueurs du
pays- de Gal sont arrivés ce dimanche
soir à Versailles une ville qui sera
leur camp de base pendant toute la Coupe
du monde de rugby pour l'occasion une
cérémonie avec des jeunes du Rugby Club
de Versailles et 400 invités étent
organisé dans les salons de la mairie si
on a voulu accueillir une équipe pour
cette Coupe du Monde c'est vraiment pour
signifier que Versailles c'est une ville
du sport c'est une ville où il y a
beaucoup
d'adhérents beaucoup aussi une diversité
du sport et donc c'est un grand plaisir
d'avoir vu cette belle ambiance ce soir
les 33 dragons rouges accompagnés par 29
membres du staff seront à Versailles
jusqu'au 9 octobre ils logeront au
Trianon Palace et ils s'entraîneront au
stade de Porsche fontaine deux
entraînements seront ouverts au public
le vendredi 29 septembre et le lundi 2
octobre en tennis l'vinois Arthur
innerkn s'est arrêté au 3e tour de l'US
Open après avoir éliminé l'italien
matateo Berettini le joueur originaire
de Saint-Jean Manly a perdu en 47 contre
le 9e jour mondial le Russe Andre rublef
le score 36 63 61 75 arthurknch était le
dernier Français en lise dans les
tableaux de simple ce 3è tour était le
meilleur résultat de sa carrière dans un
tournoi du grand schlem en football le
pisaki Mateo gendouzi jouera la saison
prochaine du côté de Rome après deux
saison passée sur la canne bière à
Marseille le joueur formé au
pariss-germain a été prêté à la laadio
de Rome avec une option d'achat
obligatoire de 12 millions d'euros hors
bonus pour son premier match ce weekend
contre Naple mattho gendouzi a marqué
mais son but a été refusé par la var il
aura de nouveau l'occasion d'ouvrir son
compteur contre la Juventus Turin le 16
septembre toujours en football la
décision est tombée l'équipe senior du
poissier Football Club évoluera en
première division de district cette
année la décision a été annoncée la
semaine dernière les dirigeants de cette
nouvelle structure qui remplaceent l'
pois si pensz pouvoir évoluer la saison
prochaine un niveau au-dessus en
régional 3 la reprise de la compétition
pour les seniors est programmée le 24
septembre enfin en golf l'Open de France
sera de retour au Golf National de 50
ans livin pour une 105e édition du 20 au
24 septembre des têtes d'affiches
françaises comme Victor prez ou
l'ivelinois Antoine Rosen devrai être
présent sur les Green si vous êtes
intéressé la billetterie est
ouverte